[موسيقى]
اخبار العالم بايجاز من غرفه اخبار
الجزيره مرحبا بكم بعد ساعات من اقتحام
انصار الرئيس البرازيلي السابق مقر رئاسه
والبرلمان والمحكمه العليا استدعاء مزيد
من القوات من ولايه عدى لدعم الامن في
العاصمه وشرطه تعزز قواتها قرب مقر الجيش
لتنفيذي قرار قضائي بانهاء الاعتصام
الرئيس البرازيلي يتواعد وبلسنارو يرفض
اتهامه
الاطراف السودانيه تبحث في اليوم الثاني
من المرحله النهائيه للعمليه السياسيه عند
قضايا عالقه مسؤول سوداني يقول ان
النقاشات متواصله مع المعارضين الاتفاق
الايطالي والسفير النرويجي في السودان
ممثل الوساطه الدوليه يؤكد للجزيره ان
الجيش سينفذ وعده بالعوده الى تقناته
في محاوله لانهاء اكبر موجه اضرابات في
البلاد منذ عقود الحكومه البريطانيه تعقد
اجتماعا مع قاده النقابيين يمثلون قطاعات
التمريض والاسعاف وثائقي القطارات ورئيس
الوزراء يقول ان الحكومه مستعده لاجراء
محادثات حول الاجور
لمحاسبتهم على الاضرار بالصحه العقليه
للشباب قطاع المدارس العامه في مدينه
سياتل الامريكيه يحرك دعوا قضائيه ضد
مالكي تيك توك فيسبوك وانستغرام وسناب شات
ملف الدعوه يتهمون منصات بالتسمم بالقلق
والاكتئاب والتنمر وغيرها ما اجبر المدارس
على تعيين متخصصين في الصحه العقليه الى
اللقاء